the incredibly dangerous tree in Harry
Potter and the Chamber of Secrets that
attacks Ron's flying car was created
using a combination of practical effects
and CGI the actual tree was built on a
hydraulic platform that could be
controlled by the special effects team
to simulate its movements I'm really
wondering how scared the cast was during
all the takes of those scenes the triple
decker bus that transports Harry to the
Leaky cauldron in the Prisoner of
Azkaban was built as a practical prop
that could actually be driven the bus
was created using a real London route
Master bus that was modified and painted
purple for the film